Hói, sân dân lợi cân xí cho bè, được không mẹ ở chủng gân dài.
Giạo quan này, chính nhiều hội nhóm chăm con,
hụt tư cân xí grow sẽ hiện linh tục,
rất nhiều phụi mình bàn táng ở chuyển tay nhau về sân tâm này.
Mẹ vì sao cân xí này lại được ở chủ đến thế?
Chưa hẹn, cân dấu rằng, cân xí là khoảng chân tiếp yêu,
có định đình quả chỉ khoảng hóa xương và giang,
đông thôi, tham gia và hỏng nực có cơ và giận chuyển thân kinh.
Mỗi hẹn, cân xí rống như người địa sĩnh xí hình châu cao
khó chỗ giống xương chắc khoảng và phát triển bàn xe.
Théo cân xí, chẻ dễ khó xương, chắc lớn,
và thật chi anh gửi biệt vận động hàng ngày, thế như.
Mặc dù ai cũng biết cân xí quan trọng, nhiều phụi mình đã thử bột dùng bằng nhiều loại khách nhau,
nhưng lại không gà thiệu quả như mong lời,
ở loại thiếu tụ cây, quốc mái mà xíu cao trọng cải tiện,
có loại lại người ta bón.
Chứ chẻ càng dự ủng, một số sản phẩm gần có mùi vị khó xíu,
với những bài biên ăn thì gần như mất khá thiệt để xuy xí đều đặt.
Tính vì những trải hiện đó,
ui ngày càng thận chạm và mong bột tiêm một sản phần càng xíu.
Chẻ hấp thu, với nhẹ nhé, người hiện đều quá lại hợp cổ vị của trẻ.
Nó cũng là lý dòng, người yêu cân kích của ông, nhé, cháu trở thành cái tên người bất.
Vì thơm nhẹ, xế ủng, quý cách mới đáu sạm ủng tự lợi.
Có thể dễ dạm mang kèo kì chẻ đi lớt,
học lý dùi ít, mất kích nó,
xanh phần gà xíu cà xí lắp tác,
lế ủng, xuống hạn chế tối ra tý chạm xíu thử người ta bón,
hãy lắm đọc cà xí, li tầm biệt tâm biệt tâm bà và cơ gà hay,
để thông khả năng gà càng xí vào xong,
đông thôi, bột xung tuyên mà xe yêu cười của nát,
xuống sân chạc quán, giở dài hơn.
Đặc biệt, xanh phần gà xíu rà dinh giữa quên xong cho chẻ trong dài đợp phát triển chêu cao,
bơi vui đa bảo tính ăn thoát lại mang lại dự qua bên vấn.
Phong có hiểu khi ở lúc cạnh kích tăng xíu grow,
được nhắc đến nhiều trong thời gian gần đây,
dài quý cính và chúng như lỗi lọt tương gặp.
Đây đang lại lựa chọn lực nhiều gia đình tình tự về đồng hành cùng các con trong dài đợp phát triển quan trọng.
Nè hai trọng ngay vào lúc cạnh kì grow để đồng hành cùng gòn trong hành xin cao lợi quái mẹ nhẹ.